[Music]
in two comfortable news what do you mean
by that
into it yeah
economists are concerned that Americans
still aren't saving despite the booming
economy I don't have any savings by
saving despite the booming if it's
booming does that mean you don't need to
say no you should be saving because you
have extra money now cuz the economy's
doing oh so now is the time to save so
when it's shitty you have something I
got no tips
who's that saying most Americans I save
pretty good Chinese style
what was it statistic I told you about
Americans or the US and their financial
education there was a seven seventy
percent are financially illiterate
I believe it oh sure you don't
understand what compounding interest I
don't know what that is it was wild I
was just like a lot of people don't
don't know that you gotta save all that
stuff that's why I'm making a program
that teaches basic ass [ __ ] on my Jamali
in school I just did one on credit cards
oh stop where do we find that well right
now it's not out I just filmed it but
it's gonna be on Jochen Sakawa calm I
think it's a big big big important thing
though people don't like cuz we can't
look we don't learn this in school I
heard that there's some programs not
some schools that are teaching like
basic [ __ ] like how to you know use
[ __ ] credit cards now you sign up for
this and get a bank account and all that
stuff right but they expect you to learn
that [ __ ] at home but if the stats are
correct and seventy percent of people
are [ __ ] up with their money they're
not teaching I don't know teach their
kid she know anything about that and I
didn't know [ __ ] until I went to college
I had to pay for like three years
school to even know anything and I'm by
then I was already in a bunch of debt so
I feel my parents taught me Chinese
style which is whatever you may know
whatever you make save half and then
live on the other half that's crazy
that's a lot but that's how my dad who
was a poker dealer paid off his house he
doesn't make very much but he's able to
pay off his house cuz you try to live on
half and then you save the other half
they'll put me through college so if
they're making like 4000 a month save to
live on - yeah
then they'll always have more but it's
dangerous because like at 18 you could
already get your first credit card right
just as giving a kid a [ __ ] bag of
cocaine yeah right now I'm like my
nephew's 19 and I helped him open his
first bank account he didn't know any of
that stuff and I'm like you better
[ __ ] put your money away every month
I'm gonna check your finances I'm like
mom Tom be Chinese about it for 50% mall
so being realistic
thank you cuz he's a kid you know kids
okay I'm not his mom because they're
gonna do whatever they want to do yeah I
could only just give him the tools and
then he chooses what he's gonna do with
it I was more responsible I saw drugs at
19 good for you no I was trying to get
paid about a [ __ ] recording studio
recording to you in my bed oh you built
one built a recording studio some
legendary songs were maybe so bloomberg
is reporting that the number of
Americans who said they have no money
readily available in either a checking
savings or money market account fell to
a seven-year low of 23 percent down from
24% last year yeah that's crazy
actually it was bank rate.com that
reported it but somebody anyway it
doesn't matter who did it
the point is it's dropping people are
saving my mom and well my parents pretty
much spent most of their lives in the
states they're in Japan now but they
ain't even save [ __ ] you know it's kind
of ironic it's the more money you have
the more easy it is to get a loan and
then when you don't have money and you
need a loan they won't give you [ __ ]
yeah yeah but it's just when you don't
have money like somebody help me like we
hope then they start giving in those
what are they shark loans or whatever
with like predatory loans yeah and
people people don't know what the
interest rate means yeah so you go and
like oh cool like someone's gonna help
me buy a house I really want a house to
get my family started right and into
like oh they're gonna loan me like what
five hundred thousand dollars at 30
percent interest a lot you know that's
some [ __ ] mafia [ __ ] right there
don't get lost I'm some guy
a purple suit yeah with stripes on it
and a gold chain and he looks at a watch
that has a pull out of his pocket what
looking like a dapper so the study here
saying that only 29% of Americans have
enough emergency savings to cover at
least six months yeah I was listening to
his podcast and someone was saying that
uh that's someone but in that podcast
they were saying right now like pretty
similar like if an emergency that cost
$400 were to occur in someone's life
majority of the people can't cover just
four hundred two hundred dollars so what
do people do just just that's why we
just use credit cards yeah either that
you're trying to ask people for it or
for $400 emergency happens you can't
cover it but then they're like but these
people also have iPhones and they have
all these others here they have a lot of
things that cost more than horn oh I'm
pretty sure I'm pretty cash broke now I
know god with the phone but you're
invested though it's different that's
why I [ __ ] put all my money into
other stuff that can make money but if
my idea of broke is like not having six
months to a year 'he's worth of income
my rule of thumb is try to have six
months to a year zwarst
like your monthly so if you spend about
10,000 a month then you need sixty
thousand two hundred and twenty thousand
if you spend that much if you spend that
much a month yeah on just basic expenses
one of the books that helped me is
called richest man in Babylon it's a
really quick read but it's a it's a fun
story like it's a real it's not like
boring it's like a guy's journey like in
Babylon like an ancient Babylonian guy
that was a slave and then he bought his
like freedom and he [ __ ] became the
balla but inside that it says out of
your paycheck put 10% away into savings
put 10% away to [ __ ] paying bills and
[ __ ] and in the rest live on that oh wow
yeah that's awesome you guys like the
richest guy in Shanghai for 50% way I
don't know there's a lot of fun ways I
think like I think people get
intimidated so they just look at it and
they go I mean right you get intimate
it's scary
a dog so what is it that make you to go
- is Skip Marley I like it but scary
yeah what is that that's interesting I
don't know I mean for me and Casey
because we're both stuck blondie got
your six months oh I hear her say it
though was she scared dancing away is
what he's asking but I just wanting away
your skirt well yeah like Casey language
is really bad with trying to put money
in certain places we just have it there
and we're just like it's there and we
don't like we're not good about having
well we do have a savings account that's
like slowly growing but just very barely
and then we just have like our business
and our personal and Mike that's it but
we don't really were not really smart
about wait like how to manage it other
than just that like those three things
so I don't know and then like thinking
about how to go about it is just
intimidating for me cuz I'm like I don't
even know where to begin like I don't
even know what to do get a financial
advisor okay Jeff you know this [ __ ] I
don't know I'm not a financial advisor I
was an auditor two different things I
don't know no it's not even to say like
points of view to opposites yeah so I'm
not good with money financial advisors
are basically they help you think big
picture in your future auditors they
look for mistakes in your business that
you have right supermicro sure or they
look and make sure that everything is on
point so everything is more like now or
what happened versus financial is like
what about your future yeah we don't
have plans like that because it could be
really simple as something as like okay
well I want to get a house when I don't
know when but at least you know looking
at the market this is the style of home
I like this might be the area that I
like and that's super basic or I know
Isaac's gonna need to go to college in X
amount of time alright well the average
cost like that super basic - that's not
even going into like the investment it's
so adult so much adult thinking dude is
so [ __ ] annoying well that's when you
look at the boring [ __ ] though cuz for
me I'm like okay I want more money cuz I
wanna [ __ ] farm where I grow mangoes
and I could drive a Jeep with a machine
gun
and I could harvest the mangos by
shooting them and shaking the tree and
the mangles fall and then I could eat
that [ __ ]
that's super basic right because you're
starting with your goal like whatever
what your where your endgame is are
these the first end is it or is it a
mango with the machine yeah what I do is
I made a hat with a [ __ ] with with
this and in a [ __ ] care at the end of
the string and I'm chasing it so you got
to make that thing yeah but the college
thing that's just boring I think don't
need college like you pay for his own
college yeah I think I'm bad or [ __ ]
that's actually what I took easy dude
I'm like I mean he's he can work it's
finally we all struggle still pay for my
college [ __ ] that [ __ ] and look at what
kind of character its building we have a
little college firm we do have a college
when super close we're calling it a
college fund but I just know what it was
like having to pay my own way he doesn't
know what it was like um so we're just
coming at it from two different
perspectives and I think we met in the
middle and we're like well let's just
give him a cushion I mean not that we
were ever against the idea but we were
just like well what like why not like
we're capable of doing it like why not
give them something a [ __ ] start it
likely [ __ ] it up that's his back yeah
we put I didn't point four or five
hundred away a month and then it
calculated to be like 30 G's by the
tower like 150 G's by the time is 18 so
if you want to go to college that's cool
and if you wants to start a business
that's cool but it's his money too if he
wants to [ __ ] it up it's cool but it's
his learn his lesson whatever whether he
gets it academically or financial or
business wise it's his [ __ ] I'm gonna go
to Vegas and put it on black I think the
most basic [ __ ] really thinking about it
is just like alright well what what are
you like immediate goals like are you
trying to have a walk-in closet you know
what I mean and I think you have these
goals and then you can set up an account
for that or different methods you know
like you can have the financial advisor
which i think is a great idea and then
just be like well how can I achieve that
I all right do you need a shot of heroin
I'll let you go what am i you you talk
anything about your own friend oh I just
do these bawling he doesn't want to
shadow they've got a Tesla David
finances though I mean whatever he's
inventing whatever he's invested what
are both kind of essence like similar
things so at that point now it's just
like I'm not missing anything else yeah
I'm pretty good so my investments are
where I put my money that's kind of make
me more money in the future yeah so like
there was a period where I was literally
working so [ __ ] hard I just like
stacked a lot of cash I remember that
part that much money and you have a
hundred thousand subscribers that's
crazy
so I I definitely stacked a lot of
[ __ ] my shows the first biggest
expense I've ever had was that Tesla
really that's really about it yeah you
know I mean other than that I mean you
guys don't see me flash in anything else
[ __ ] junkie I heard you're wearing
Gucci flip-flops right now oh yeah these
[ __ ] reef football a shape I found it
yeah but other than that you know
there's not much I really spend on you
know do you save money David says like
crazy lives well below means this year
probably in the last year I haven't
saved as much because I just haven't
been working as much stuff in terms of
like making immediate money you know I
definitely haven't done that but I'm
always make sure that I always have the
the bases covered and then some you know
so I'm not balling out but I'm not gonna
be [ __ ] poor you know and that's
that's the important part
yeah because the investment part is
already done now people say money isn't
everything but a lot of [ __ ] problems
divorces issues stress comes from not
handling your finances right trust me
I've seen that [ __ ] [ __ ] hurt
people's lives
[Music]